The X-Men are not currently part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, but if they were, the
only X-Man to survive the Snap would've spelled
big trouble for Thanos.
Speaking with IGN's Up at Noon show, Avengers:
Endgame directors Joe and Anthony Russo revealed
the one member of the team they would have
left standing, and they have some pretty solid
reasoning behind their choice.
The Russos' conversation with IGN involved
a thought experiment in which the pair were
asked about several groups of people, some
fictional and some not, and which members
would have survived what Marvel refers to
as the "Decimation."
When it came to the X-Men, they didn't hesitate
to assert that only one mutant would have
made it: Wolverine.
Upon being handed a picture of some popular
X-Men, Joe Russo said:
"This is going to be interesting.
I'm going to do something very controversial."
To the surprise of the hosts and encouragement
from his brother, Joe began striking team
members willy-nilly, taking the time to point
out that even through Thanos wiped out half
of all life in the universe, it doesn't necessarily
mean that every specific group of people would
have been halved.
"Hawkeye's entire family disappeared.
So any given group, you could lose almost
everyone in that group."
Russo then presented his handiwork to gasps
from the hosts.
He explained the thought process behind his
choice:
"I'd love to see a--" "I don't want to give
you the rest of these cards."
"--fiercely motivated Wolverine going up against
Thanos."
It stands to reason that nothing would motivate
the near-indestructible hero quite like the
only family he knows being wantonly wiped
out by a genocidal intergalactic warlord.
It would have been quite a contest.
We know that Thanos' mighty sword is capable
of damaging vibranium, given what it did to
Captain America's shield.
But we haven't seen Thanos go up against adamantium,
the metal that makes up Wolverine's claws
and covers his skeleton, in the MCU yet, though
it has happened in comics.
After that difficult choice, the Russos were
then presented with a series of similar scenarios,
revealing in each instance which members of
popular groups they would have chosen to dust.
For the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, Joe
Russo claimed to own a copy of the very first
issue of the comic, saying "I love these guys."
But that doesn't mean he would have spared
them all.
The choice was so tough he deferred to Anthony,
who benevolently spared them all.
Lest the hosts think him soft, though, Anthony
deadpanned:
"Remember, you're talking to the guys who
iced Spider-Man and Black Panther."
Next up was Scooby-Doo and the gang.
Fred, whom Joe called "kind of worthless,"
and Shaggy both bit the dust, presumably leaving
Scooby, Velma and Daphne with unstoppable
thirsts for vengeance.
After that, the duo was handed a photo of
the cast of Friends.
As the Russos mused about the slim likelihood
of an entire group having the misfortune of
being totally wiped out, Anthony marked an
X over every face.
At least Ross wouldn't have to pine over a
dusted Rachel for five years.
After briefly misidentifying a Member of the
Backstreet Boys as New Kids on the Block's
Donnie Wahlberg, the directing brothers decided
to leave only one standing: Nick Carter.
They didn't seem to have any particular reason
for this; Nick just got lucky.
It's all random, anyway.
"I offered a solution."
"Genocide."
"But random.
Dispassionate.
Fair to rich and poor alike."
Having earned the attention of Marvel Studios
partly due to their excellent work on the
beloved series Arrested Development, deciding
which Bluths to wipe out had to have been
a tough choice for the Russos to make.
Maeby, Buster, and Tobias all bite the dust,
with Anthony explaining that Tobias had to
go because he thought it would be funny to
hear the blue man's final words, with David
Cross doing "40 variations" on the line.
"Oh my God, we're having a fire!
Sale!
Oh the burning!
It burns me!"
For the cast of another comedy the brothers
worked on, Community, Pierce Hawthorne got
dusted, with Anthony noting that he, quote,
"could use the five years."
Joe then mused over what choices would be
heartbreaking narratively before finally choosing
to spare everyone else.
Disney's deal to acquire Fox didn't go through
soon enough for an epic throwdown between
Wolverine and Thanos to become a reality,
but Logan will surely be a part of the MCU
at some point in the future.
If Thanos ever manages to return, viewers
might get to see them go head-to-head, and
Wolverine has gotten the better of the Titan
once or twice in the comics.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.